I'm nervous I don't know how to start
this video I found another PewDiePie
quiz email to me by Malcolm underscore
1466 how old is Peter Pan he's the one
that made all these [ __ ] quizzes and
here we have the PewDiePie IQ test we're
gonna do this IQ test I'm gonna destroy
it I'm gonna [ __ ] you Malcolm I'll make
you sign a contract so yeah is your IQ
as low as a full [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you let's do this
number one which word doesn't fit in
seeing screaming smelling or hearing
screaming is not a sense it doesn't make
any sense so I'm gonna go it's creamy
that's right Malcolm suck by deque I'm
sorry please if you're only if you're
over 18 and if you want to alright so
number 2 complete this chart start okay
do I like minecraft No
no way Jose do you have a girlfriend yes
did you meet online
yes it's she hi totally are you lying
[ __ ] yo no liar
[ __ ] you what happens if we say are you
lying yes kill yours oh my god that's
not okay Malcolm you can't joke about
these things all right
alright let's try that again do I like
minecraft yes do do you have a
girlfriend no it's not funny do I like
minecraft no way do you have a
girlfriend no do you watch Petey poop
alright next one if you come to the
answer kill yourself at dives as
instructed thanks you come to the answer
well done you are in the path of
successes it says well done nowhere here
the only thing well done is your ass
once I'm done with that [ __ ] from the
offered options please select the
picture that logically best fits to the
freecell obviously it's jacksepticeye
alright there's gonna be a [ __ ] troll
here and the right answer it's not gonna
be here why is there a [ __ ] three
there I would say the tiny pac-man face
no matter what situation PewDiePie is
always wrong correct answer circle there
wasn't even a [ __ ] circle I stopped
[ __ ] the word racecar is spelled the
same forwards as n backwards
well let me see a race car oh [ __ ]
that's awesome I didn't know that okay
so obviously it's true/false better luck
next time
awesome I would flip this table if I
could all right begin wherever you want
draw one line through all of the doors
but you cannot go through the same door
twice okay
[ __ ] I gotta do this otherwise I fare
goddamn this is hard I can't [ __ ]
solve this test am i that [ __ ] stupid
this doesn't even have a [ __ ]
solution I don't understand these are
holes not doors PewDiePie channel has
over 42 million subscribers if you
remove 10 million subscribers how many
subscribers disappeared if I have uh
okay let's that's 32 they are all BOTS
anyway oh come on how is this even an IQ
test why am I here why do I have a baby
do you have blonde hair yes
sorta I don't know do you have blue eyes
yes
are you a Nazi are you Swedish yes go in
a [ __ ] yeah do you have blue eyes no do
you like petabyte yeah do you like Peter
pie you're gross do you play dota yes
contact
well you trying to get hooked up with
dota if you come to answer e to take
advice as instructed if you count your
answer to contact me call this number
please don't call if your troll please
this is a private number
maybe I'll I'll call your mom later
number 8 Felix has no subscribers jinn
has money
Felix hands over his balls and sells out
for money
gen gets pays all the money Felix only
in it for money gets subscribers
goddammit [ __ ] gen what a [ __ ]
question number 9 can you draw a key in
my hand yeah
there you go she has no quiz made by
Malcolm 1466 if you scored low on this
test you are probably as rate err
Richard ray-ray [ __ ] as PewDiePie
cuz he only in it for the money
subscribe to Malcolm 1466 for comedy
video subscribe wait
he has a YouTube channel know anyone
alright thank you so much for watching
this video if you enjoyed give it a
thumbs up and then always professed
what's the name of pair two PI's girl